STEPHANIE WONG: This week,
we're talking about retail
in the Cloud, Cloud
Run, and scaling SAP.
I'm Stephanie, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
With 700 stores,
longtime retailer
Macy's has looked to Google
Cloud for data management
and analytics.
Google Cloud CEO
Thomas Kurian dives
into how GCP is
helping them streamline
operational functions.
Check out the full article
to learn more about
how Google Cloud is helping
retails work faster,
smarter, and more securely.
So you're excited about
the release of Node 12.
And you just can't
wait for systems
to add new version support.
Why not run it on
Google Cloud Run?
Using the function's framework
and a little bit of code,
Cloud Run can be set up
to easily deploy a Node 12
function.
Breeze through this step-by-step
guide by Grant Timmerman.
Still searching for reasons to
start building on Cloud Run?
How about 12 more.
Check out this
blog post to learn
exactly how Cloud Run
complies with each part
of the 12-factor
app methodology.
It's simple.
These factors act as a blueprint
to build applications that are
scalable, portable, and agile.
Take a look to learn how
Cloud Run and the 12 factors
square up.
You can see why
Cloud Run makes it
easy to scale serverless apps.
But what about apps running
on virtual machines,
like SAP Server.
Check out these best practices
for scaling SAP Server
on Google Cloud, and you'll
also get an in-depth comparison
of the two main approaches--
utilization-based auto scaling
and schedule-based scaling.
Get ready for the
intelligent enterprise.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.